je vais te dire quinze jours qu'on roule
pas à combler super g en profiter pour
vérifier la liste
ok ok c'est parti quand on est ok papier
oui ok acheteurs j'ai brûlé coca et non
c'est sûr je prends le risque
attention virage à droite à droite
partition qu'il n'est pas fini on va
sécher je sais depuis longtemps vague et
si tu vois je suis bien là attention aux
piétons
où ça trois ter san indigènes ont
augmenté leur connaît elle avait des
tapis des grêlons faudrait signaler aux
organisateurs des feux rouges sur un
antihéros habitants sont pas comme il a
dit oui ça sent la merguez un couscous
et ouais le monde high art mature je le
fleuve ya pas de problèmes criants fait
c'est qu'elle soit blanc brillant que
cette ville et des quoi il ya un
problème j'ai vu marquer pour le web on
va pas dire rien ils ont construit
récemment déclenché la narration des
chances c'est défendre quoi vais je dire
je fais pareil dakar ya cinq ans cette
édition de des champs de maïs maintenant
attendu reconnaître avec le fait qu'on
en voit tellement vivant presque plus
longtemps les autochtones la fête même
des bagnoles savent pas s'en servir
bref c'est ça ma peine on appelle la
concorde aux heures de pointe
j'écoutais la radio nova et m'a dit t'as
du tiercé de 6-2-2 jeunesse bien hôpital
de lyon on a fait la vache ils bougent
pas passé l'afrique ça oui ayé d'enfer
soyons l'impression qu'ils ont marqué
ouais d'accord je supporte pas les lions
ont passé bonheur jédir brasseur
balavoine tous derrière un nouvel
abattoir sera pas bon
le truc est paru chez l'agent pour aller
à dakar
ouais non pas la gare à dakar adacore
qu'est ce qu'il a dit la direction qu'on
attendait pas ça je suis coincé il a
regardé en me rendant à rigaud voilà ces
lois là c'est bon c'est la fois avec mes
ses portes à ses balises est grave elle
va attraper froid je supporte même eu
raison des fous rires
avant d'accueillir tous arrivent en
fuite
ouais bon bah écoute là quand j'ai
demandé un supplément d'âme mademoiselle
monsieur
dakar 7 à combien oui combien 1500 3000
à 2 l et es je crois qu'on n'est pas
arrivé